residential architecture in general is
going to go through quite a bit of
changes over the next few decades the
important thing though to think about
when you think about a field as vast as
residential architecture you have to
think locally because a house in New
York is a lot different than a house say
in Seattle or in India or in England
each of those cities has different
forces acting on it in New York you're
gonna see apartments get smaller and
smaller so Mayor Bloomberg had an
initiative for 250 square foot apartment
micro apartments which currently is
illegal in New York but as you start to
shrink the apartment size architects are
thinking about how to make up for that
lost space with new social amenities new
public spaces new ways for people to
interact with each other and with the
city when we think about the future of
houses lately the big buzzword is the
Internet of Things and the Internet of
Things is going to change the way that
we live the same way that the iPhone
changed the way that we communicate but
it's hard to understand exactly how
that's going to resonate with
architecture right now I think one thing
that's a lot more obvious is the
Internet of Transportation and when you
think about something like uber and as
that starts to grow and people stop
owning cars that's going to have a
massive effect on the cities where we
live all of a sudden we're not gonna
need giant parking lots we're not going
to need parking structures streets will
be able to be shared by cars and by
pedestrians as cars get smarter that's
going to have a gigantic effect on the
buildings that we build the Internet of
Things right now as it's affecting the
houses stuff like the nest thermostat
which is a smart thermostat that you can
also control from your iPhone or from
your phone as you're away from the house
it's about smart locks that you don't
need a key for it can recognize you or
the digital signature of your phone to
open up the door for you houses are
getting smarter things are getting
smarter refrigerators are gonna know
when to order food for you that's all
amazing
but that's not necessarily directly
going to impact the spaces where we
spend our time so when you think about
designing a house when an architect
designs a house that's a that's a huge
responsibility for an architect because
this is this is the place where people
grow up where they have dinner with
their family where they fight with their
family or they love their family the
space is shape those relationships I
know in in my house growing up I had the
bedroom that was right off of a balcony
so everyone would see me going to the
bathroom and everyone would see me in
the towel and I was like I was a fat and
awkward kid and I hated that I hated
that that feeling of everyone seeing me
and that a hundred percent shaped me
into Who I am today that physical
experience of occupying a house and the
decision that one architect made ten
years before I was born
made me and gave me the personality that
I have today
that's an awesome responsibility that
architects have